cuphead people love cuphead the new
video game look at the reviews everyone
loves it people are saying cuphead is a
pretty challenging game but I just have
one simple question is it just like Dark
Souls the whole mean with Dark Souls of
gaya shooters or Dark Souls of puzzles
Dark Souls meets fire watch Crash
Bandicoot has become Dark Souls the Dark
Souls of space breath of the well is a
little bit like Dark Souls every game is
like Dark Souls man let's go to my
favorite video game journalist website
polygon to find out cup editor
repetition of being difficult
it isn't the Dark Souls
oh really
polygon turns out you're wrong because I
have done a little bit of journalistic
work myself I have found some evidence
to show our elsewise this is a footage
of games journalists which I'm not gonna
name who apparently spent 25 years
riding for games and this is him playing
the tutorial I absolutely love the art
direction of this game it is incredible
you know he can't seem to make this jump
that you know I haven't played the game
myself so I don't know but maybe you
were seeing it already it kind of went
viral just because of how god-awful it
is I'm a huge fan of 1920's 1930's
animation cartoons it's something that I
used on my channel in the past is like a
mid segue it just has such a warm
endearing feeling to it attached to it
and just the style and intention to
detail is just incredible and seeing how
well they implemented that in this game
you know it's an original idea to do
that make that constitute game but you
can tell that they really put effort
into details and making that possible he
did it thank God in there in his defense
he tweeted out spoken by someone who
hasn't played it yet
do me a favor and capture your first
honest 26 minutes okay it's time to do
this what you are about to witness is
the first 26 minutes of PewDiePie
playing cuphead unedited raw footage
because I've got stuff to do today and I
haven't got time to edit it I'm sorry
I'm honestly a little nervous maybe it
is section
[Music]
okay here we go
is it Satori all right okay okay oh I
didn't even know I had to press shift it
was so intuitive oh my god wait wait
wait wait
no no he used to controller I don't mean
to sound like an elitist or whatever if
people are bad at games I couldn't care
less but if you're writing reviews about
games
how can anyone trust what you're saying
when you clearly never bother to play a
game properly
how can you struggle with this you don't
even have to press the direction I love
it this game is so pretty
hey you know what this game is just like
legend of the brofist my stuff
oh my god that's so cool
x-ray points okay I love everything from
the music to just how they they die and
they explode or whatever so cool I guess
this is my first 26 honest honest
minutes pretty challenging not gonna
like surprised I made it this far I must
I must be extremely lucky
look at these skills I haven't even
played 25 years I played more like 22
got them the heck oh wait these are the
ones that can parry up a god I thought
the random did I just take damage in
Dark Souls it doesn't work like that
oh look at it did the jumpy my god
seriously what the heck this game is
impossible no are you kidding me I was
soaked the whole thing
you best be joking
fine you know what fine I died on first
level okay everyone needs to chill what
the hacker is this
there you go look at that look at those
skills left and right
oh my god why did I go for the coin I
was right at the end you know what you
know what yes the game is hard whatever
[ __ ] this is really embarrassing
there's things everywhere chill fam Hey
look yes look at that
how long did that take me 26 minutes
hell yet keep in that a place give me
that a place come on a push I'm an
a-plus game or everyone they would say
eight plus eight this game is just like
doctor that's the only well that could
have been that could have been really
embarrassing what
this is a boss so I think originally
this game was supposed to be just like a
boss game or whatever but if you've
received so much attention that they
wanted to make it into a full game which
I'm playin it this reminds of Sonic so
much this game is just like Dark Soul
Sonic this thing ever tired okay fine
whatever whatever zero that's okay that
doesn't count what the hell let it make
no sense
[Music]
you're not fine I don't want to play the
stupid boss anyway stupid games stupid
whatever this game is whatever okay shut
up what do we have here
the thing is that I remember with old
games they all used to be hard like back
in the day I never was able to finish so
many of the games that I played like
don't you come country or whatever but
that doesn't mean I enjoyed it less I
think nowadays when developers have so
much statistics on everything they know
exactly if a person finished the game or
not what places they died [ __ ] it just
created this attitude that everyone has
to be able to finish the game otherwise
it's not a good game when that's not
necessarily true at all that is just a
my little lot about difficulty in games
this boss is insane dude look so for
we're fighting the Illuminati carrot
Itzik so I am turned on
[Music]
hey it's a knockout first right just
zero deaths there are death just like
duck shows just like a dark side
give me that A+ fan but you have to
parry three times to get all the five
skill level skill level look at that
skill level I knew I was gonna love it
before I played it and goddamn I love it
damn you gotta have at least godlike
reflexes to deal with this boss I'm
guessing I have to shoot these
Oh No what is happening what do I do
[Music]
well that one's hard dude you never know
what's gonna happen I can forget Oh what
the hell oh my god what am i doing I
think I have to parry it okay there we
go what do I get a frog I got a frog
thanks
whoa whoa whoa hey hey hey so cool
come on give me something good tiger
oh wow oh yeah
another one no are you kidding me
sighs easy bit I guess I have to do it
three times but man I can't this is hard
it goes faster Mike tempo is off and did
it last one step it coin come on stupid
Jam give me a challenge please Oh game a
little hard game it's too hard
none of my get Tim what give it a pulse
I don't even know how these work
[Music]
/ it's a knockout everybody zero that's
zero
just like journalists I'm sitting with
skills God look at that first right that
was my first try look at that
what do you mean that isn't Perry what
do you mean what do I have to pay rate
that was ten out of ten baby get a de
how do i Perry seriously I don't know
how to Perry I never Perry in games okay
I never do it really another boss dude
how many bosses are they oh I have to
defend the
[Music]
okay all right okay how do I get rid of
me I got a pair of them don't touch much
[Music]
but I did parry three times good night
just like tennis you know you go and
then you go back you go and then victory
first driver body first ride thank you I
defended the earth just like Dark Souls
[Music]
you know that's the only thing the game
is missing the iconic voice acting I I
think I could do a good job at it I love
the game I think it's so fun I can't
wait to just play more but we're gonna
end that episode there now should anyone
be shamed for being bad at games
absolutely not but should a game be
judged differently because it's
difficult get out of here go home then
you don't understand difficult games
aren't just there to make it challenging
it's to make it rewarding when you beat
it isn't that obvious maybe that's
obvious but it really doesn't seem like
it when you see every single news outlet
compare difficult games to Dark Souls
because that's all that matters
have you guys read all you need is kill
it's a manga based on sort of the same
concept that every time the the guy
isn't very good at fighting you know but
every time he dies he gets to try again
and then again and again and again and
soon he becomes like this master of the
same war scenario and it's the same
thing with games you know you not you
don't necessarily have to make it at the
first try and then by the end of it
you're you're a master of that level and
you complete it perfectly and you get
that sense of hell yeah I learned
something I became better at something
and that's what's the fun is anyway
that's kept it for you leave a like if
you enjoy watching squad fam out
[Music]